hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three satisfying games
i've never done a three games like this
before because i've never really been
into satisfying things
but i came across an app while i found
room smash the game where you blow up
things
and that's about it
and then um i saw i saw this other game
called
foil foil foil
roll the foil foiled no that's what it
said is the top that's the instructions
what's the name of the
foil foil voice what the frick is a
foil file foil man
you foil in the plan and you foil man
stand the foil man
here oh what's the frequency name
that's probably not the name of it the
actual name of it is
foil turning 3d anyway so it's about
foil right
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
is there no audio to this hammer it
replace all these sound effects with uh
you making the sounds with your mouth
do it i i command thee to do it
i'm assuming that you exactly did
does this actually happen i have to go
get aluminum foil and try this i don't
actually have anywhere i am right now my
where ma'am where my
where i am right now i highly doubt that
if you were to actually do this that it
would turn out to such a mirror shine
like this
is this it paint it
what is this what people do do people do
this
do people do this what yay
my reward is an ad shown
[Music]
put sun god damn you freaking idiot
where's the x there's the x was that it
peel the paint what do you mean
peel the paint what
[Music]
how'd you do that how did how did you do
that
steve rake
[Music]
i don't i don't want any reward no
thanks
i bold
[Music]
oh i didn't fail apparently
thank you like why is this teaching
children
how to make a homemade knife
i feel like this is highly irresponsible
alexia and i hope you're still making
the sound effects just reuse
reuse if you don't feel like going the
distance
i thought you wanted these videos to be
high quality you know i thought i
thought that maybe you know you would
lay it all on the line
it really is relying on you all of this
is relying on you that is a
quality knife this is a great knife i'm
really glad
another freaking ad jesus oh wait i
could just
if i turn off wi-fi won't that fix the
problem
okay yay peel the paint
next hey i have a knife
[Music]
get it what do you mean get it get it
lexie and please sing all around me are
familiar faces
mad world you know the one oh my god
all around me are familiar
but also make the piano your voice as
well
and if you didn't do it before now redo
it
now with leave what you did before
already and do it
please i'm sorry you don't have to do it
[Music]
all right this was super fun and
everything i am done with you
i'm going to soap cutting
[Applause]
wow okay what is it
what is it what is
[Music]
oh you did it you did it congratulations
i'm really proud of you
what happened what happened to your eye
what happened to your
eye man i love mobile ads i love mobile
hey
so oh okay i gotta keep
[Music]
blah
give me the cat hell yeah look at that
cat
oh this looks like a good
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
okay this is actually pretty cool i like
i actually do enjoy this
i think this is this is actually kind of
dope
that's a cutie that's a cutie you know
honestly i've never been watched for
much for watching satisfying videos
but i get it you know it's like asmr you
know i don't really get
the effect
yeah i don't really feel the effects of
asmr like a lot of people
and i know that this probably has a
similar thing for people and i don't
really get it from that either i like i
understand it it's appealing but i don't
get the
like the tingly asmr type feeling also
this is a nightmare
freaking decapitated monkey head in my
soap
ooh
[Music]
[Applause]
it is very scary to to be carving
through these and then have a pair of
eyes be staring at you
like i'm about to chop your head off
it's got hands that's an ant
it's horrible it's horrible i don't want
the mystery but i miss
out screw you hey look at this weird oh
that's different
oh that's different okay that's
different
oh that's very different okay
i'm not as well i'm not nearly as well
does the other one this is underwhelming
special level huh oh happy face sad face
sad
[Music]
bladder
ice cream and i shouldn't eat that no i
should not eat that that's not going to
be good for me
i i definitely shouldn't eat that ooh my
knife collection
yes my knives yes
knife collection a diamond wow
i got three keys i don't know what that
means
they're scissors
who put scissors in my soap who the hell
i was watching
all right whatever oh they're safety
scissors okay i'm picking box
[Music]
oh my god i am a goddamn god
look at me go i did it top prize i
didn't get it next level i'm gonna do
one more and then i'm gonna go
24 karat gold i am literally destroying
gold why would i be doing this
why would i be satisfying a bar of pure
gold
it's gold wow that's pretty good
i used to play when i was in college and
like i got my first smartphone i used to
play nothing but coindozer
like i would just play a lot of coin
dozer because whenever me and my brother
would go to like dave and busters or
something like that
you know we would just play the coin
dozer games because we were really good
at the coin dozer games and so we really
enjoyed playing the coin dozers
it was kind of like there was a certain
one and there's a soccer game if you
know the soccer game
it's like the moving guy if you know the
recipe to get around
the soccer goalie there you can nail it
into the bonus
uh bonus hole every single time they
actually removed that game
the coin dozer game from that one uh or
they changed up the scores because we
were just getting monster tickets we
were getting like every single token was
getting us a hundred tickets bonus
plus what was being pushed down below so
really in all honesty we were kind of
destroying the system you know we we and
and
and even so later like the coin dozer
games any coin drop type game is always
going to be better for your buck because
me and my bros we were out and we we did
a coin drop
dozer and we were able to nail it on the
bonus tickets for the minions game every
single time we got so many cards and so
many decks
and we got so many everything so that we
were able to get a lot we we got the
xbox
long story short we got the xbox one
tonight one night we all got the xbox
blam blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah guitar this is
[Laughter]
i'm that just
really caught me off guard oh boy i can
shank someone
i don't know why that one really tickled
me
i'm done get out of here i'm done with
this get out of here i got one more
so this is super slime simulator so at
the heart of everything satisfactory
what what kind of slime simulator needs
you to require to take
data from me what data are you going to
obtain
what in the hell are you going to do
nothing to
know what in the hell perhaps it's slime
slime let's figure out what super slime
simulator actually collects
please know the type of information
automate collected is non-personal
information that includes your session
durations the content you access on the
app the frequency and scope of your use
of the app and information about your
device the internet connection including
the operating system and browser types
information from which you can be
personally identified may also be
collected including but not limited to
your name email address telephone number
or username and the location of your
device for which you use the app
dronematon offers a variety of
activities including activities that may
collect
information from children
you know because that's important
you are always in control of your data
personal information if you choose to
receive information from us or others
you can
change your mind later if at any time
you would like to stop receiving such
information or opt out of a feature you
may notify us but by writing to support
dramaton.com hey dramatan
[ __ ] off how's that for a clear concise
email what notifications
do the freak you it's slime
i was gonna do that you [ __ ] you
i'm
i don't like the sounds this is like my
moment here and you're really stealing
the thunder from me
can you stop fingering my slime
please get there we go
i hate this i hate this
get away whatever
god damn shut go a wet milky
milky milky i don't want
milky slime am i really
lotion activator
stir it up i've made
milky slime get a little blood in my
milky slime
you know what i'm okay i don't want to
add a color it's milky so i i really
didn't
want to add all right pink okay
[Music]
why won't you let me be me why won't you
let me be me
why will you not let me be me i don't
want ladybugs i don't want
bugs in my slime i don't want
bugs in my slime
dramatic this is so horrible
travis said no
dramatic shut up why do you want me to
keep
driving shut up
[Music]
drivers and there's too much drama
here i hate you so much dramatic
god i just wanted some milky white slime
what am i doing what am i
doing there
[Music]
[Applause]
can i just play with my slime please
thank you that's good
stuff there we go that's it's
really you know my milky wa
why are you dramatin you goddamn
[ __ ] you
terrorizers of people trying to have an
enjoyable
what what i don't want to
screw you let me play with my milky lime
oh my god i swear dramadin
dramadin dramatin dramadan
drummaton eat drum a dick okay i wanna
play
with mark's milky lime you collect this
data [ __ ] collect
this data [ __ ] collect my data here
here's my data you see my my beefy data
well that was that okay i'm glad that
that
i'm glad i feel pleasantly satisfied and
everything is good
these are quality games quality gaming
experiences
and it reminds me why i love the mobile
gaming sphere
so much honestly the soap cutting not
that bad
soap cutting was pretty good i like the
soap cutting everything else
can uh collect this personal information
here
okay that's the personal information
that you get to collect i'm gonna keep
keep cutting me some soap
i thought it was an egg it's a honey of
course
it's i am
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna five
stars
cancel so that's all thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to be
satisfied further and want me to do more
satisfying things and give you my
honest opinion of various mobile apps
let me know and i will
i'll do that you will get my honest
opinion you won't like it
well you may like it but the people that
made the apps won't like it
check out other videos that i've done
and the recommenders over there there's
tons
it's like a lot that's like a lot of
videos that i've done probably
thank you for being here and being you
and as always i will satisfy you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
bye